hi i am stern giannini senior product
manager at google cloud welcome to
what's new in serverless
today we are mainly going to talk about
two of our serverless products
google cloud functions which is
serverless functions and google cloud
run which is serverless applications and
containers
first
i want to call out that serverless is
available in every google cloud region
you will find
and cloud functions in all of the google
cloud regions
and you can expect us to open up those
products in future google cloud regions
all right
let us dive in into cloud functions
so first
we've been hard at work delivering new
runtimes for cloud functions new
programming programming languages
the first one is ruby
then is.net core
php
and we've also been updating our
existing runtimes
with python39
and node.js 14 and even 16 in preview
next we added more
customization to the build process
so you might know that when you deploy
your function
on cloud function the first step that
happens is that this function is built
before it gets deployed
so you can now customize where that
build happens by
targeting a private worker pool
this allows you to customize the machine
types on which the function will be
built
or to ensure that the function is built
within your vpcsc perimeter
we've also added the ability to define
build environment variables so these n
valves are m valves available at build
time they for example help you configure
the big pack behavior
and finally
we delivered min instances to cloud
functions
so
we've been hearing from you that
call start is a problem with function as
a service so what is a call
when your function receives no traffic
its number of function instances are
scaled to zero
but then when traffic arrives
cloud functions will scale from 0 to 1
and the time it takes for the function
to start is what we call a call start
thanks to mean instances you can simply
define a value
that cloud functions will scale down to
keeping one or more instances one
so that when the next request comes in
there are already some warm instances to
process them
so when not in use those warm instances
are charged for memory but also for cpu
at 10 percent the price
to use mean instances you can do so via
simple command line flag or
user interface input
right now i would like to connect two of
the google cloud orchestration products
that pair very well with cloud functions
and cloud run
the first one is called event arc
so event arc allows you to
asynchronously deliver events from
google services software as a service
and your own apps to serverless products
event arc has added a few new features
the ability to target cloud functions
the ability to
receive events from cloud storage
and a new standalone user interface that
allow you to manage your event arc
triggers in a central place
second i want to call out workflows
which is google cloud product to
orchestrate automate
google cloud and http based api services
with a workflow that you define
so on the right you can see a screenshot
of the user interface where the workflow
is using a
comprehensible syntax
but can also be visualized in a very
nice graph
so workflows
has added a few new features
first the ability to use http callbacks
the ability to connect to many google
cloud apis
it has increased the memory as well as
the number of concurrent executions
and there were many syntax and library
enhancements
all right now let us dive into cloud run
so first i want to call out that we have
added committed use discounts to cladram
so committed use discounts allow you to
commit to an early spend
on cloudron
for a year
and you would you simply receive
a 17
discount on this commitment
of course usage above the committed
amount is charged at normal rates
this is self-service from the cloud
console you go into billing you click
commitment and this is where you can
purchase a commitment for a year
i should note that
committed use discounts apply to all
clad run services of your account across
all of your projects
for a given region
let's take an example
on the right
we can see an example clad run bill over
time
this basically reflects the cluttering
usage over time
as you can see
because most of the time the bill is
above one dollar
it makes it very economical in that
situation to commit
to a one dollar per hour
usage
because that means that
you would only pay 83 cent
for every hour
and of course if usage goes above the
commitment for example
because you used 1.5 dollar of cloud run
then you would only pay the discounted
on the one dollar
and
50 cent
above the dollar
now i want to tell you how we have been
improving the clarion developer
experience with three things following
the development journey
first we have added local development to
cloud run
second we are making it easier to deploy
your source code
and third
we improved the observability of your
cloudant services
let's take a look
local development
this allows you to run your cloud run
services in a local emulator
this emulator is available in the gcloud
command line in the cloud code for vs
code in cloud code for intellij as well
as in cloud shell editor the online
ide of google cloud
if we take an example
you can see that you can store your
cloud run config in a file that would
allow you to define
how the emulator should be configured
then using a simple command
gcloud beta code dev
you start a local development
environment that will emulate
the characteristics of cloud run
with the cpu and memory allocation that
you defined with the environment
variables that you've defined
and it will
watch your local source code for changes
and when they happen we'll rebuild them
into a container that and restart the
local server
so quite handy for a fast development
loop instead of deploying to the cloud
for
testing your changes
then
once you have developed your service you
want to deploy it we have added support
for deploying source code to cloudram
this is basically a command a very
simple command in three words that will
build push and deploy your service your
from local source code
this command is gcloud
run deploy
that's right that's the default for
gcloud run deploy it's to
build your local source code using cloud
build push it to artifact registry and
then deploy it to cloud run
this command is also leveraging google
cloud build packs in order to allow you
to deploy source code in popular
languages without any docker file that
includes go nodejs python java and net
but of course if a local dockerfile is
present then this command will simply
build it with the instructions that are
in the dockerfile and deploy the
arbitrary container image to cloudra
lastly we added more observability to
cloudren
first by delivering a few more metrics
notably the instance count metric which
will show you simply the number of
active and idle instances
for a given cloudrunned service
then we've worked with the cloud error
reporting team
to
make sure euro reporting was able to
capture
system errors out of the box
so without any more configuration that
means that if your claron container
instance
is out of memory
or if claudran is not able to scale
because it is reaching its max instance
limit
those errors that are present in your
logs will now also be aggregated in
cloud error reporting and displayed in a
very actionable way in the cloud1 user
interface
and lastly
we have collaborated with the cloud
trace team to provide out-of-the-box
request tracing
that means that you can now analyze the
latency of your cloud on services
using cloud trace without any
instrumentation needed
all right now i'm going to tell you how
we
have made it
easier to run more workloads on cloudrun
with three changes
first
giving you more control around the cpu
allocation of your service
second by delivering a new execution
environment
and third by pushing the limits
that were historical limits of cloud run
let's take a look
cpu allocation
let's take an example
here you can see
one
container instance of a cloudant service
it is starting
then it is started it receives requests
potentially multiple requests at the
same time thanks to concurrency
and then at the end of its life it gets
terminated
today
the cpu for that container instance
would only be allocated when the
container instance is starting
or when it is receiving at least one
request
as a customer you would also only be
charged
when the cpu is allocated
and in particular you are charged for
cpu and memory
but also you are charged every time a
request arrives
we are introducing the ability to opt
out of this cpu throttling by simply
saying that you want the cpu to always
be allocated to your container instances
as long as the instance
is alive
so in that case
you would be charged of course for the
entire lifetime of that container
instance
but the cpu will always be available to
that container instance
you can enable this via a simple command
line flag on an existing or a new
service as well as a simple checkbox in
the user interface
so this new option to always have cpu
allocated allows you to run background
tasks or async processing after you have
returned
requests
it makes cloudron more compatible with
monitoring agents like open telemetry
many programming languages
do things asynchronously like go
routines or async or threads or core
routines these are no
more compatible with cloud run
and lastly you can deploy spring boot
apps that are expecting to do background
things
and as i said when you opt into this new
cpu allocation to always have cpu
allocated
you are charged for a different price
there is no request fee
and the cpu and memory
is 25 percent lower
you can couple this always on cpu
allocation
with mean instances
basically allowing you to have a number
of instances that are always
scheduled and which always have cpu
unlocking some quite interesting use
cases
next
you will find that we've improved the
performances of
cladram as well as we are adding network
file system support
this is thanks to a new
execution environment that we call
second generation
so basically when you deploy a container
image to cloudran it runs in the
execution environment
also known as sandbox
so today you can opt into the second
generation execution environment
again using a simple command 9 flag or
user interface button
and this new sandbox has increased
network and cpu performance has better
linux compatibility
and allows you to use network file
system like cloud file store for example
and next i should call her that we are
constantly at work to
increase the limits of cloud run
so first we have added support for more
protocols like web sockets http 2 and
grpc bi-directional streaming all of
these are generally available now
you can now pick up to 16 gigabytes of
memory in preview
up to four vcpus
each request can
run for up to 60 minutes
and each container instance can process
up to a thousand concurrent requests at
the same time
this can become very handy if you are
using web sockets and opening many
streams on a given instance for example
lastly i want to tell you how we have
made clardon
even easier to secure
by meeting regulatory frameworks
by allowing you to put a secure
perimeter around your cloud and services
and by helping you secure your quadrant
services
so cloudron is now covered by these
regulatory frameworks we know this is
very important for enterprise settings i
should call out fedramp moderate pci dss
stock 1 2 and 3.
all of these
are now
covered for cluttering
next how can you
secure
or define what is allowed to
reach your cloud and service
well first we have added support for
ingress control
by default
all traffic
at the networking layer is allowed to
reach your cloud and service
but you can now restrict the ingress to
only allow internal traffic so that
means traffic from coming from your vpc
or from google cloud like cloud pub sub
and you can allow internal traffic plus
traffic coming from
google cloud load balancing
similarly you can control um where the
outbound request should go
for example when you do an outbound
request to the internet you can force it
to go through your vpc
and by using ingress and egress settings
you can also enable bpc service control
allowing you to put your clogging
services inside a vpcsc perimeter
thanks to cloud-run integration with
google cloud load balancing you can
leverage cloud armor which is a web
application firewall
and you can use identity aware proxy to
build internal applications that would
only be accessible to your employees for
example
and lastly i want to tell you how we
made it easier to secure your cloudant
services
first
by providing a native integration with
google cloud secret manager
so secret manager is a google cloud
product to store your secrets in
a secured place with potentially your
own encryption keys
you can now mount those secrets as
volumes or as envars
inside your cloudant services
allowing you to decouple your code your
container from its configuration or even
its secret
then we added more security features
of course you might know that cloudant
services run with a certain identity so
that means you can provide a service
account that will be used as the
identity of the code that runs for for a
particular service
and this service account can have more
or less iem permissions
notably you can remove all permission
of a certain cloudant service if this
one is not expected to call any apis
we are announcing the general
availability of binary authorization for
cloudran
binary authorization allows you to
define a policy
regarding which containers can or cannot
be deployed to
cloudrun
and by using
an organizational policy you can enforce
binary authorization to be applied to
your cloud and services in a set of
projects lastly
we delivered customer manage encryption
keys allowing you to bring your own
encryption keys
to encrypt the container images deployed
to cloudram
and finally we haven't stopped here we
are proactively producing
recommendations to secure your cloud on
services
the first one that we delivered is to
recommend you to use a dedicated service
account with a minimal set of
permissions for each production clutter
and services
so to recap
we have added many things to cloudrun
the first is committed use discount
allowing you to get a discount of up to
17 on the amount you commit
we've improved and we are continuously
improving its developer experience
with local development deployed from
source code more metrics
we've increased the workloads that you
can deploy to cloudrun
with cpu allocation controls a second
generation execution environment or just
by pushing the limits of of cloudran
and lastly we made it easier to secure
your cloudant services
to learn more about serverless i
recommend you those three sessions dev
100 which is a great introduction to
serverless on gcp dev 201 which will
deep dive into some very cool features
of cloud functions including some that
are coming
and dev 205 which will teach you how to
build event driven applications with
event arc and cloudrun
thanks for joining me today this was
what's new in serverless enjoy the rest
of cloud next
you